you're just being jabbed constantly
[Music]
beautifully with needles as a kid am i
with there is a difference between a
hand poking and tapping I think
definitely watch her got to get it and
it was kind of freaky what's your name
so this kind of freaks me out - I'm
thinking like it's gonna be like a
gigantic long time what are you looking
forward to must have something on my
shirt my name is Rachel Perelli and I'm
a tattooer I do both machine and hand
poke Rick and I work out of my house WTF
hand poking and poking is exactly what
it sounds like
I strap a needle through a piece of wood
and Pope you manually over and over and
over again how deep you it's not deep
it's not as deep as a shot it's kind of
like paper cut level
I hate paper cuts I hate getting
tattooed it's not as bad as yeah why do
you think it's like a trend now even
with machine tattooing there is an
element of sort of like technology
coming into the body and the artwork and
when you take that away you get
something that's a little bit more
I don't know precious a little bit more
special I mean you have to be focused to
be able to do it it takes so long and
it's a little bit cool wings
kind of like a labor of love I think
there's so much stuff about your body
that you don't get to choose you know
size shape color texture or whatever and
it feels really good to be in control of
one thing this is my body I'm gonna make
it look like what I want it to look like
let's send this directly to my mother
I'm writing a mirror you ready you're
going first all night I can't believe
I'm getting on my test it is a little
bit I know it's gonna be really painful
all right so what are you thinking
orientation wise that the tops that
stick stuff down yes okay
[Music]
sometimes it's not that bad
[Music]
is such a great job
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
we just got tatted I do survive so I'll
say all in all it really wasn't that bad
as I anticipated I definitely have maybe
I might have psych myself out a little
bit more than necessary
I feel like afterwards
diminishes a lot oh my god the popping
oh it's puncturing your skin every time
so you can physically hear like some
poop so gross [ __ ] about the siren
but yes I would do it I love the
experience all in all I definitely do it
joking hands hope they'll get stabbed
but your bike
[Music]